this is a map of East Asia in the 19th
century and you can already see
significant Imperial control by Western
European powers you have the British
East India Company in India you have the
French initially getting a foothold in
South East of Vietnam in this orange
area but eventually they will take over
this entire region that will become one
day Vietnam Laos and Cambodia
you have the Dutch in Indonesian you
have the Spanish in the Philippines but
we're going to focus on in this video is
the European and in particular the
British attempt to open up the Chinese
markets to British trade China at the
time under the control of the Ching
dynasty well before this period Chinese
products were in demand in Europe in
particular Chinese porcelain and Chinese
silk unfortunate for the Europeans the
Chinese did not have a lot of demand for
European products and so you had a
balance of trade problem these products
would be exported from China into Europe
and you would have hard silver currency
going to China and so the imperial
powers especially the British were
looking for a solution and they
eventually found that opium grown in
India which is a highly addictive drug
it's the core constituent of heroin and
morphine could be addictive to the
Chinese people and maybe could help
solve this balance of trade problem that
silver could then flow outside of China
well you could imagine the Chinese
government the Ching dynasty had no
interest in opium coming into China it
was destructive to their society it was
an addictive drug but in 1839 the
British decide to force the issue and
you have what will be known as the First
Opium War this is a picture of the
Second Battle of 20 you see the British
vessel nemesis which is actually owned
by a company the British East India
Company destroying Chinese junk ships
and because of this show of force in
this military superiority they were able
to win the First Opium War and extract
major concessions from Ching
China the Chinese had to open up five
ports to trade with the British they had
to give the island of Hong Kong to the
British indefinitely and the British
would keep control of it all the way
until the end of the 20th century the
Chinese had to pay for opium that they
destroyed they had to give reparations
to the British to pay for the costs of
the war now to add insult to injury the
British were not satisfied and in 1856
you have the Second Opium War where they
try to extract even more concessions
from China after which opium is
legalized the whole time opium flooding
into the country and really undermining
the social fabric of society to make
matters worse for China you have a major
civil war in this time period the
Taiping rebellion which was started by
this sect of Christianity that viewed it
as their destiny to overthrow the Ching
dynasty and this is one of the most
bloody civil wars that any nation has
seen in history with over 20 million
people being killed and historians
believe that the Ching concessions to
the British and then the French and also
the opium that was undermining Chinese
society was a major contributor to this
long and bloody civil war these opium
wars are often cited by Japanese in this
time period as a reason for their need
to industrialize and become imperial
power so that they don't get unraveled
the same way that ching china does by
the europeans but to appreciate that
this was even controversial in Europe
William Gladstone as we enter into the
First Opium War was a young
parliamentarian in Britain and he will
eventually be at the end of the 19th
century a significant British prime
minister but as the opium war was
beginning he gave a famous speech in
Parliament it is a matter of certainty
that if we stopped the exportation of
opium from Bengal and broke up the depot
at Linton and checked the cultivation of
it in Malwa and put a more
stigma upon it that we should greatly
if not extinguish the trade in
it the great principles of justice are
involved in this matter you and he's
talking to
I believe the foreign minister who is an
aggressive proponent of the opium wars
you will be called upon to show cause
for your present intention of making war
upon the Chinese they gave us notice to
abandon the contraband trade the trade
in opium when they found that we would
not they had the right to drive us from
their coasts on account of our obstinacy
in persisting in this infamous and
atrocious traffic and opium was
addictive and William Gladstone had
personal experience with this his sister
became addicted to opium he went on to
say I am not competent to judge how long
this war may last but this I can say
that a war more unjust in its origin a
war more calculated in its progress to
cover this country with permanent
disgrace I do not know and I have not
read of and a few days later he wrote I
am in dread of the judgments of God upon
England for our national inequity
towards China